♪ ♪
>> Laura: EXPLOSIVE NEW COURT
DOCUMENTS SUCH AS FORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
MICHAEL FLYNN WAS SET UP.
WHO HE WAS SET UP BY?
JIM COMEY.
HANDWRITTEN NOTES ON SALE
TONIGHT SHOW THE FBI DISCUSSED
USING JANUARY 2017 INTERVIEW
WITH FLYNN "TO GET HIM TO LIVE
SO WE CAN PROSECUTE HIM OR GET
HIM FIRED."
IN OTHER WORDS, TO ENTRAP HIM
AND RUIN HIS CAREER.
AND THEN OF COURSE LATER ON YET
AT TRUMP.
WITH A HANDWRITTEN NOTE AND THIS
INTRIGUING LITTLE SNIPPET.
IF WE ARE SEEN AS PLAYING GAMES,
THE WHITE HOUSE WILL BE CURIOUS.
JOINING ME NOW IS CONGRESSMAN
DEVIN NUNES, HOUSE INTEL RANKING
MEMBER AND SEAN DAVIS COFOUNDER
OF ""THE FEDERALIST"."
LET’S START WITH YOU, A LOT OF
REVIEWS OF THE PAST THREE YEARS.
YOU HAVE BEEN DIGGING INTO THIS
AND TAKING INTO IT, BUT THIS HAS
TO BE ONE OF THE MORE EGREGIOUS
ABUSES OF POWER GIVEN HOW WE
KNOW THIS THING WENT DOWN NOW.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> WELL, CLEARLY, GENERAL PLAN
WILL HAVE A CIVIL RIGHTS CASE.
AND I THINK IT WILL COST THE
GOVERNMENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
SECONDLY, HOPEFULLY, THERE WILL
BE SOME PROSECUTIONS FOR THIS
MATTER.
AND THE JUDGE REALLY HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO STEP IN AND
SANCTION THESE LAWYERS.
AND WITH ALL OF THAT SAID,
LAURA, WE BROUGHT YOU THIS.
THE HOUSE REPUBLICANS BROUGHT
YOU JUST A SNIPPET OF THIS
INFORMATION BACK IN 2018.
WE WERE MOCKED.
WE WERE TOLD IT WAS A JOKE.
NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN, YOU REALIZE
WHAT WE TOLD YOU AT THAT TIME,
NOT ONLY WAS IT TRUE, WE DIDN’T
EVEN KNOW THE HALF OF IT.
EVEN RIGHT NOW, YOU DON’T EVEN
HAVE THE HALF OF IT.
THERE IS MORE INFORMATION COMING
OUT THE REST OF THIS WEEK.
THE EVIDENCE IS CONTINUING TO
PILE UP IN GENERAL FLYNN’S
FAVOR.
WHICH IS WHAT WE TOLD YOU AND
WHAT MOST OF US KNEW.
I’VE KNOWN GENERAL FLYNN FOR
NEARLY 15 YEARS.
AND TO THE IDEA THAT HE WOULD BE
A RUSSIAN AGENT IS PREPOSTEROUS.
>> Laura: IT IS A DISGRACE HOW
THIS ALL WENT DOWN THE PIER OF
THE MEETING WENT DOWN.
THE INTERVIEW TO BUILD A
CONVERSATION, SEAN.
HERE IS WHAT JAMES COMEY SAID
ABOUT THE FATEFUL FLYNN
INTERVIEW BACK IN 2018.
>> WE PLACED A CALL TO PLAN AND
SAID HEY, WE ARE SENDING A
COUPLE OF GUYS OVER.
WE HOPE YOU WILL TALK TO THEM.
HE SAID SURE.
NOBODY ELSE WAS THERE.
THEY INTERVIEWED HIM IN A
CONFERENCE ROOM IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND HE LIED TO THEM.
THAT’S WHAT HE PLED GUILTY TO.
>> WHAT DID HE THINK THEY WERE
COMING OVER THEY ARE FOR?
>> I DON’T THINK HE KNEW.
NO, WE DIDN’T TELL HIM.
>> Laura: SEAN, THE HUBRIS OF
JIM COMEY, MY BLOOD BOILS
WATCHING HIM.
HIS MANNERS, HIS PRIGGISH MANNER
THERE AND HIS DISMISSIVENESS OF
THE RIGHTS OF AN INDIVIDUAL.
YOU HAVE BEEN DIGGING INTO THIS
TONIGHT.
TELL US YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> RIGHT.
I THINK IT IS CLEAR NOW THAT
JAMES COMEY WILL GO DOWN IN
HISTORY AS THE MOST CORRUPT FBI
DIRECTOR IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
HE HAS HAD THE WORST REIGN.
HE HAS DESTROYED THE FBI’S
REPUTATION THROUGH HIS ACTIONS,
HIS ARROGANCE, AND HIS
CORRUPTION.
HE HAS MADE IT MORE DIFFICULT
ACCORDING TO A FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR THAT I SPOKE TO TODAY
FOR THE U.S. ATTORNEYS AND FBI
AGENTS TO GET CONVICTIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
THAT WILL FOREVER CHANGE
JAMES COMEY’S LEGACY AND AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Laura: REMEMBER HOW THIS
DID GO DOWN, CONGRESSMAN NUNES.
THEY CALLED HIM.
I DON’T KNOW, WAS THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL INVOLVED IN
THIS AT ALL?
DON MCGANN, SALLY YATES, HOW DID
THIS WHOLE THING GO DOWN?
BUT YOU DO.
SO REMIND US HOW IT WENT DOWN.
>> WELL, LET’S REMEMBER THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING.
AND ALL OF THE RUSSIAN HOAX, WE
HEARD ABOUT ILLEGAL LEAKS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT LEAK AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL WHERE THE
TRANSCRIPTS OF FLYNN HAVING A
PRIVATE CONVERSATION.
THE INCOMING NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR FOR THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH A RUSSIAN
AMBASSADOR LEAKED OUT TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND OTHER
PLACES, I BELIEVE.
NOW WHY JAMES COMEY AND THE FBI,
WHY 400 FBI AGENTS CRAWLING ALL
TRYING TO FIND OUT, OH, MY
GOD, WE JUST LOST AN IMPORTANT
TAKE THE RUSSIAN INVESTOR AND
SOMEHOW THAT LEAKED OUT FROM THE
IC?
WHAT DID THEY DO?
THEY DID NOTHING.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, WHAT
HAPPENED IN THAT PROCESS?
WHAT THEY DID IS THEY DID NOT,
THEY HAD McCABE, DEPUTY FBI
DIRECTOR CALL OF GENERAL FLYNN
AND SAY SOMETHING LIKE, OH, WE
WANT TO SEND A FEW PEOPLE OVER
THERE.
OKAY.
SO NO, HE DID NOT HAVE LEGAL
COUNSEL.
THEY SET HIM UP.
THE WHOLE THING WAS A SET UP.
>> Laura: SEAN, THE MEDIA,
THEY DO NOT ESCAPE CULPABILITY
IN ALL OF THIS.
BECAUSE RATHER THAN BEING REAL
JOURNALIST, THEY WERE ROOTING
AGAINST THIS PRESIDENT AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION FROM THE START.
REAL QUICK.
LET’S WATCH.
>> THIS GUY WAS NOT ONLY ACTING
AS A AGENT, LITERALLY AS A
FOREIGN AGENCY NOT
METAPHORICALLY.
WHAT WE ALL KNOW NOW, FLYNN WAS
A DOUBLE AGENT.
>> WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE GOT WAS
A BLISTERING REVIEW FOR MADE-UP
CLAIMS THAT FLYNN WAS SOMEHOW
ENTRAPPED BY THE FBI.
IT WASN’T JUST A JUDGE WHO DID
THAT.
IT WAS MICHAEL FLYNN.
>> Laura: WILL ANY OF THEM
COME ON TELEVISION TOMORROW AND
APOLOGIZE OR DO A MAYO COPPOLA?
SEAN, WILL ANY OF THEM HAVE THAT
DECENCY?
>> NO, IT WILL NEVER HAPPEN
DESPITE THIS ENTIRE HOAX COULD
NOT HAVE BEEN PERPETRATED
WITHOUT THEIR WILLING WORK IN
IT, NO, THEY WILL NEVER RETURN